[Music]
you guys are so cute
what are you guys doing just hanging out
hanging out in our new room yes in our
room that has been this way for a couple
weeks we just haven't filmed it yes we
haven't vlogged we stockpiled so much of
uh our travels I know but then now we're
like you know what
what there's a lot of change
a channel that's fill you guys in and
give you some life updates so for
starters we have our room back as you
can see uh my desk is over there it's no
longer a crib in that corner so Luca has
his own room now oh he's moved into his
own room and he's been doing so good
he's been sleeping in his crib there's
only
sometimes two wake-ups in the middle of
the night where I have to go feed him
but usually it's just one and I don't
know he's just doing so good he's such a
big boy now we're so proud of him and so
right now I'm currently in the middle of
decorating his whole room and just
creating that space for him there's just
so many different things around the
house that I've just been really eager
to share with you guys so for starters
you want to talk about what kind of
shoes you're wearing
yeah for starters do you like my shoes
these are my new slippers they look like
a bubble waffle yeah so they're
like so I don't know I found them on
Amazon
so you can check out my Amazon I'll link
it for you guys if you like them they're
super soft and really comfy yeah so oh
man there's like a smudge here
no I cleaned that that was
that was a lens that's so funny all of
our viewers are like you guys just
constantly have smudges on yours lenses
I know when I was editing I was like
what's the point in editing any of this
this is just garbage there's a big black
dot in the middle of the screen and oh
wait hold on this is really cute
foreign
[Music]
all right so yes our room is very
different we've got uh got my desk here
now I was enjoying having my own office
before now my son has taken over the
office space because kids need their own
room right I guess I can't have my own
office I have to share my own office
with my sleeping area with my office and
with her office come on Luke is so
selfish we gotta look right here I also
have
um my current project which is cutting
stars out so I bought this big decal
thing for Luca's room
to put on the ceiling which this is for
his ceiling fan and so my plan is to put
the moon on the ceiling fan and then
stores all around the ceiling and they
glow in the dark so that's what this is
also what I use my desk for is for
pumping late at night I have my pump kit
right here and I sit here and I pump and
I put away in the tiny little fridge
which then later I take down to the
freezer so this is my function here very
nice it's a pumping station really
pumping and also I have my computer here
so working sometimes nice never
yeah you're a stay-at-home mom now how
is that like for you I love it you're a
stay-at-home mom that has projects and
all the projects have are happening down
the hallway right over there yeah where
the sun is shining through is where
everything is happening but you guys
won't see it in this video not until
it's finished we're actually in the
middle of making a whole video about his
Nursery so once that's all done you guys
will see his Nursery so stay tuned for
that video hi Maya you know what I feel
like the cats have been very neglected
since Luca's arrival yeah they
definitely have you actually lost weight
too true especially though so where is
though so Zoe lost a lot of weight uh
recently and it kind of coincided with
Luca um coming home and we actually took
him to the vet to see what was wrong
with them we thought we thought maybe
it's a hyperthyroid situation rant test
blood tests x-rays all sorts of things
came back negative so I guess we're just
chalking up to the fact that you know
there's a lot of change at home and you
know anxiety is kicking in Maya our
other cat was gaining weight and so one
of the problems was their feeder the
previous feeder we had would just
dispense food into one bowl and it was
up to them to kind of hash it out like
how much they would eat and obviously
Maya was winning so when pet Libro hit
us up to try their new automatic theater
the timing could not have been better
which by the way thanks pet Libra for
sponsoring today's video so the pet
Libra feeder comes with two stainless
steel bowls lunches and a splitter
system that evenly distributes the food
between bowls portions are adjustable
and it holds up to five liters of food
all right so one of the coolest things
about this feeder is the fact that it
has a camera right we can monitor and
checking on our cats whenever we want to
from anywhere and so came back up to the
room and let's check in on our cats the
camera is super wide so you can see
everything that happens you can talk to
them too in that button in the middle oh
cool talk hello
hello
they got scared yeah hi Zoe and Maya
what can we pause it's really cool
because you could also record or take a
screenshot you could also like retrieve
video stream from a different time like
if you wanted to see things from say
nighttime yeah there's also night vision
which is pretty cool in the camera look
at our cats they're eating together like
one big family they don't have us they
at least have each other while they're
eating that's true you know when you eat
together just like with humans
pets also need to create that bonding
around a you know a meal so at least
they have that I really love this feeder
I'm so glad that I put Libra hit us up
because I was just like oh my God we
really need to get a feeder but there's
two bowls because it was such a like it
was such a concerning event to see
zeld there's so much weight and it might
have gaining weight we're like okay this
is a problem but now ever since we
switched over to this feeder it's been
awesome oh my God especially with all
these trips that we've been going on
it's been fantastic to actually like
schedule their feedings and see it all
in the app because with the previous
feeder that we had like we didn't have
an app and we couldn't see like there
was no camera or nothing like this is a
complete upgrade now if you're worried
about how much your cat is eating such
as us because one cat eats too little
apparently and one cat eats too much pet
Libra allows you to set automatic times
for feeding to make sure your pets get
the exact meal portions they need make
sure to check out our description for
the link and use our code Tiff case for
15 percent off your feeder highly
recommend it if you have fur babies
definitely check out pet Libra all right
and another change that we have in this
home is Lucas playpen it's right there
taking a bar entire tiny living room we
also have this camera here that
shouldn't be here and waits that
shouldn't be here but but Casey just he
hasn't gone around to putting them away
so we used to have Luca's play mat here
but then now that got moved to his room
so another change that happened here in
this living room which is funny that it
happened now and not before when the mat
was here is the fact that the cat's
litter box is no longer in that corner
so we had the kitty box back there and
it was really annoying because the
silica would get everywhere even though
we like put those you know those spiky
mats that we have in that corner we had
them here on the coffee table so it can
create kind of like a Runway and so they
could avoid the play mat but there was
still like little kitty litter pieces
and we had to like wipe it down every
every time we would put Luca down to
play and all that stuff anyway point is
now the kitty litter is here in the
closet I found this really cool thing I
forgot what it's called but it's this
device that allows your door to stay
open by like putting it in there the
crack is just big enough for cats like
this is an actual thing that's like
meant for cats so if you buy so many
cool things thanks I know I find a lot
of cool things on Amazon we have so many
cool things that you can find on Amazon
I feel like you should definitely do
like an Amazon finds oh yeah I've
actually been wanting to do that so if
you guys are interested let me know I
have so many like weird quirky things
that I find on Amazon that I'm like oh
my God I just want to share them with
you guys so anyway that's one of them
and I'll include my Amazon storefront
Link in the description so you guys can
check it out for yourself but yeah I
plan on doing like a future video of
like Amazon finds or whatever let me
know if you guys are interested in that
so anyway now the kitty litter is in
this closet so we don't have a light
here but I have this really cool light
that I also found on Amazon that has
like different color temperatures but
anyway we have this light here oh and
it's also portable by the way so I've
got to charge it that's why the lights
blinking
so kitty litter is in that corner and we
have like the little play mat thing and
then kind of created like a little I
don't know like a little pathway for the
cats to come out here so because of this
this new system their kitty litter does
not end up out here at all so it's a lot
cleaner I also bought this container to
hold all of their Kitty food because
this is a in this closet it's where we
would keep their Kitty food but now I
have it in this container it has wheels
on it too which is really cool love it
it's also in my Amazon storefront so now
this is like the new system we have
their clean litter here extra bath
tissues and all that good stuff but yeah
it's been a lot better like a lot
happier with this system
and then we just close it here
and then it's ready for kitties to go in
there and they have their privacy over
there and like their kitty litter isn't
like messing up like the floor and
getting everywhere love it love it love
it love it another thing is
Lucas high chair so I don't know if you
guys remember but we had a different
high chair before I actually decided to
get a different high chair because
looking into baby lead weaning for Luca
we realized that he needed a foot plate
to like have his balance and to like
properly eat like you know proper eating
posture and so anyway we got the Ikea
high chair but I decked it out so I got
this really cool thing called uh catchy
which actually catches all his food got
the foot plate ended up like wrapping
the Ikea legs because it's like a gray
like a silver color but now it's like
fake wood we also got this really cool
matte this is on my Amazon this is on my
Amazon
um also the foot plate and the wood
grain thingy but not the catchy oh no we
actually I think it is on Amazon too
anyway got this stuff so this is his
eating situation and over here he has
his bouncer on the island because
whenever I'm cooking and stuff like he
doesn't like being in the play play pen
that much so put him in the bouncer oh
also these just came in yesterday and
I'm so freaking excited so I custom made
i Custom ordered these to fit this bench
exactly because this bench is like kind
of weird configuration or whatever like
it's a really weird Dimension I ended up
getting these custom made and it has a
grip at the bottom and they're so spongy
also got these on Amazon I am loving
this it's like amazing because every
time we'd sit here like the other ones
they were too big so they would always
fall and I the cats would always end up
pushing it to the floor it'd be on the
floor and then they would use it as a
little cat bed but now we have these new
ones and they can't so I love it another
thing is you see that out there let's go
outside this is a lot going on here you
might be wondering what is happening
here so this is Luca's new wallpaper and
I'm off guessing it so we ended up
ordering this wallpaper we put one roll
up already and it made his entire room
smell like vinyl like intensely to the
point where we actually had Luca
sleeping in our room for these for like
three days because his room smelled so
intense so I'm like this can't be safe
so once the the other two rolls came in
I was like okay let's off gas it let's
have them lay out here for a couple days
so we can make sure that his room won't
stink by the time we install this
wallpaper so that's why they're out here
and also by the way update I don't think
I ever told you guys about my plants but
as you can see they didn't survive
that was like a year ago but I had all
these pots filled with my plants I was
pregnant at the time so I couldn't
really keep up with them in terms of
like the pesticide stuff I don't know
they just died and the the remaining
ones the succulent ones I don't know
they're hanging on for dear life but I
they're like neglected my plants I
neglected my kitties and my plants
because Luca on my attention went to
Luca which is where it needs to be
anyway
so because we changed the office into
Luca's room we had to figure out where
to put all the office things like the
futon yeah it looks like you got pissed
off at me stuff out of your garage
I know so this is what our garage looks
like right now let me turn on the light
as of right now we have all these things
here so these are all the things that
were in the office that belonged to
Casey slash me because like my sewing
machine is there and like cutter thing
but yeah like lights we don't tear these
down because every week we're taking
pictures of Luca to like track his
growth and then these are some things
that Isaac does doesn't want anymore so
I have to get rid of but yeah we have
the futon here the coffee table and a
dresser this dresser I was intending to
sell but now I think we might end up
keeping it to store Casey's camera stuff
because we really don't have room for
anything
um these chairs and this ladder I'm
planning on hanging up on the walls we
also have Casey's
um canvas that he really loves and so I
don't know I'm thinking about hanging it
somewhere if there's room I had this
extra wreath that I kind of don't want
anymore because it's kind of like bare
but I thought it was funny if I hung it
here to like kind of mask it like oh
yeah it's a pretty living room minus all
the
the junk and then uh same with these
sticks here so I don't know we're like
trying to like fake a loungy kind of
place I also have the intention of
buying a rug so you can have a rug out
here and like just kind of like a
hangout spot but not really because I
don't think we're really gonna ever use
it to hang out maybe later when Luca
gets older and he's like on a little
tricycle or something we'll probably
like open the garage door and have them
play out here I don't know but yeah
that's what we got going on over here
um it's a hot mess but and I had to like
get rid of a lot of things because on
this side there's this white shelf that
we no longer want a few other stuff here
that I'm like okay we gotta get rid of
these things once that's gone then
hopefully this garage will look really
nice and just really you know something
like where we can Lounge because I
already like built all these cabinets
and we got this refrigerator we could
only fit one car in here originally we
wanted to be able to fit both cars in
this garage but now that we have this
whole living room situation we're like
oh okay I guess just one car oh you
might be wondering too like why don't
you just sell this stuff that you have
here and then you have enough space
because we really like these items and
once we eventually are able to move into
a bigger home we want to take these
things with us so that's why we're not
getting rid of them we're just figuring
out a way to make room for them so
there's just been a lot of moving pieces
in this home and yeah I just wanted to
give you guys a little update oh yeah
and another change is the fact that we
now have our trash can outside it used
to be inside right by the island but our
cat Zoe figured out how to open this
trash where we put like all our food
scraps so you figured out how to open it
and he figured out how to activate the
sensor and we caught him in the trash
once so because of that reason we now
have our trash out here hi though
you already ate buddy one more eating
for you oh yeah look he is gaining a
little bit more weight but man he was a
lot skinnier like he's pretty skinny
still but he's definitely been gaining
more weight my poor baby my fur baby so
yeah so life has seen a lot of changes
recently for us you know we see Tiff
being basically being a full-time mom
now a lot of you guys have been asking
me like what have I been up to and it
was actually working for Disney for some
time working before Disney is actually
pretty fun but most recently right now
I've been working on a project with a
pretty well known YouTube channel known
these guys for a long time and they
recently reached out to me to direct a
project for them and so I'm actually
busy uh revising a script went location
scouting and taking a lot of production
meetings with them it's a collaboration
that I feel like has been in the making
for a long time but I can't wait to
shoot it edit it and to share it with
you guys I think it's gonna be a pretty
cool project so make sure to be on the
lookout for that
[Music]